remember when people used to talk about
saving money I literally you and I grew
up in an era where that was a
conversation that people were like that
was a word that people said there's not
a [__] under 25 years old that
even wraps their head around the idea of
like I'm gonna work
and I'm not gonna go into credit card
debt I'm gonna live within my means
and save 10 or 10 20 of my take home we
are now in a place of zero savings
full debt full debt and we don't own it
all to buy [__] all to buy [__] that
doesn't mean [__] the inner Nation what
is good a pretty exciting podcast today
uh we continue to try to bring some of
the brightest and most exciting Minds in
the world uh this uh gentleman is one of
the few people that has been on the
podcast more than once he's putting on
all sorts of helmets if you're listening
at home there's a spark element now we
got a army hat if you're watching the
videos you'll see it Damon John uh world
renowned entrepreneur investor
um but all around good dude and so uh I
uh it's really nice to have you on the
show brother I hope you've been having a
great summer the last time I physically
saw you were sitting apart from each
other at a Knicks Heat playoff game and
I was texting you I don't think so I
don't I think I think I was at V con
after that was I oh you're right that
was after was it you're right thank you
sir you're right I just want to bring up
the Nyx heat thing because I'm still a
little salty because I felt like you
were clapping for the heat in Miami and
I was like wait a minute tell me educate
me you know I I got some closure at B
con because I know at vcon you sit up
there and you say yo cats don't get to
me you gotta understand in high school I
you know I've been a Jets fan you said
something like you was like so nothing
can get to me so um you know we'll we'll
get back to this helmet later
um but you know I realized that the
Knicks have lost
for 40 years now Gary I want to make
sure that you understand a lot I know
that you somewhat think you understand
business and I'm pretty good at it but
they have a job their job is to win for
40 years they have lost yes I'm not sure
if any of our employees if you would say
hey by the way it's 50 by the way 1973
it's actually 50 now 50. okay so yeah
you know you know the chef you know or
the person who does the catering if
after two weeks you you're starving and
you're like I didn't eat I think you
would fire the person well good news the
mix have gone through a lot of players
in the last 50 years
anyway look I know we don't have a lot
of time and I'm excited to have you on I
just want to go right into this I think
one of the reasons I was excited to have
you on is I've been thinking about just
having people that I think are doing
things I admire I think can bring value
to the audience in a podcast and
literally the only question and then I
just want to Spring off of it is what
are you up to what's on your mind what
are you most passionate about what's
interesting what are some of your
observations what are some of your
conclusions what's brewing or what's
what do you have closure on that's a
full belief those are the things running
through my mind
yeah things running through my mind that
is a big question but you know uh I I
think all of us really go through that
every single day unless we're blindsided
by the fact that we're having a
temporary form of success in one way or
another and we're thinking that for some
reason it's not going to go away but
usually no uh normally we have a healthy
paranoia so if I have to think about the
entire scope of everything I'm doing
right now is number one of course I have
a dedication to entrepreneurs from Shark
Tank because it's not a game right
they're they're they're livelihoods are
you know are there and even if I quit
today I still have five to ten years of
being uh somebody of value to the ones I
invested in I'm thinking about what do I
do as this world has changed I have uh
in I have remote employees uh I have
other employees that work next to me
every single day I knowing taking my
inventory I do not want to have I don't
want to be a Gary where I have a
thousand two thousand people it's a lot
of uh responsibility uh when I when I
topped out it was 500 400 employees so
what do I do where I get to really be uh
the point where I have a small amount of
people that I know all their names right
I know everything they want to do in
life because when I had when I had 500
employees you know every time there was
we had to stop doing birthday cakes
because birthday cards were coming in
every day and I was like well
yeah exactly right so um so how do I
keep it small but yet how do I make a
Major Impact globally using all these
new devices and Ai and all the things
that are changing and then of course you
know sometimes you can draw on an
opportunity People Like Us I'm over
billion dollar funds every single day
hey Damon let's do a fun no luxury
funding this and that and it sounds good
but at 55 years old uh to it's not that
easy you know when you were raising
capital from people and if I do if I go
around to whatever 20 30 people and
raise These funds well the teachers
union or pension they're not giving you
50 million about you showing up in
Geneva or some other place every other
day now you times that by 20 people and
then you have some billion dollar fund
you have a lot of people reporting to
you you have to report to a lot of
people and then my quality of life goes
away because I'm giving it all away and
not to my children so I don't need 20
houses so what the hell do I need a
billion dollars for so I have to think
about purpose yes at the end of the day
and how does that equate to my health my
family uh my experience and my time and
yeah your joy yeah my joy yeah I hear it
right through your mouth like it's a
very
it's I love the last minute or two
because what I'm hearing and it's so
right which is
it's a three-dimensional game of you
know entrepreneurship in life right of
course you know of course especially for
you and I and for many people listening
um when you the money part especially
when you don't have any of it early on
it's just so black and white it's like
that's a thing yeah yeah I need to feed
my family it's pretty simple you don't
have anything yes but then as you like
go through the processes that we've gone
through whether our own accumulation of
more paper or more interestingly for me
and I have a feeling you're gonna jump
in on this you start looking at the
people that are generation or two ahead
of you now that we're 47 and 55 we have
a lot of contemporaries ourselves who
are in places of achieving certain
things and you just kind of get to this
place with where you're like man I know
Unlimited
sad anxious depressed miserable wealthy
people
and like what the [__] is that about
that's not there's nothing interesting
about that and then you get into a place
of like oh if I'm gonna play this you
know I hope you're thinking the same way
I am my great hope for you is with
modern medicine and the way we all roll
now you know 110 is not impossible for
us you know and so if you've got 55 more
God willing you know you'd like to kind
of [__] enjoy it to the best of your
ability and that definitely isn't going
to be money at all costs that comes in
Impact purpose Joy you know it matters I
mean U.S final we are at the greatest
time and you agree with me we're the
greatest moment in our lives where
listen you know what uh put it like this
if if you're that everyday person right
now who is growing uh I'll give an
example you know because we are so
tempted and it is our ego too that is a
little bit of a I can do this but you go
to a place and I love I invested in a
restaurant I remember about 10 years ago
because I love the chicken wings they
were amazing I said you know what great
I go there I have a good time the feel
of everything think chicken wings I'm
Gonna Make You know what I'm gonna then
start doing these chicken wings Frozen
I'm gonna make them all over the place
whatever when I started having to deal
with the labor and the the inventory and
all that I never went back to that
goddamn place again because I just
wanted to enjoy the damn chicken wings
and I should have just left it at that
yeah right
um and but today like you're saying you
know I heard listen Kim Kardashian had a
has gotten a lot of different uh uh uh
uh uh hate mail because she went to a
place called pronubo that I went to
about a month ago I wouldn't get this
full body scan no radiation they find an
aneurysm or a Baker cyst in my leg in
the back of my leg now my friend who
just sewn The Who unfortunately passed
away J.R redinger who first vacation he
took in 30 years on his 85 million
dollar yacht
um he had a pain in his leg he went down
downstairs and unfortunately he's no
longer here because of an aneurysm so
immediate I was petrified but because I
got that 25 or 3 000 and I understand I
don't want to be telling that I got that
that that that that uh that renewable
thing I went I was able to check it and
realize it was just a baker's cyst but I
have a freedom of uh of you know thought
to know that I'm okay that's what
technology is today but why am I saying
that because technology is to the point
where uh you know I'm having things on
the Ebu machine and I'm draining my
blood to see and what I'm doing is uh uh
um uh ozone in my blood to see how much
inflammation on my body technology is a
great point but we can live forever now
I'm gonna pay it I'm going to touch on
that Kim Kardashian thing for a second
everybody slander Kim 2500 three
thousand dollars but you know what
unfortunately maybe then some of those
people standing outside of those luxury
uh stores that I see online all day long
that ain't got it maybe they won't be
able to afford a bag for another six
months but they'll be able to live for
the next 20 years of their life or
before
take the point of where we are today and
forget if you can't afford a 25 or 3 000
uh you know uh thing like that if you
work at McDonald's and you know you get
every year one physical go get your
blood checked to see if your white blood
cells are in line or whatever it is
right Gary my point is that technology
today is there my favorite thing Oprah
did ever is she's done so many iconic
things was she had a huge audience
really go to the doctor on their
birthday the big agenda she pushed on
her show and I watched women across this
whole country during that you know era
where she was that person in society
create new behaviors in a positive way
and to your point in a world we live in
now this is my number one point of
social media to a lot of friends
you I tell my friends you posting a
picture of you on a private plane break
down for me how that's valuable for the
person that's receiving on the other end
and then and you know what they'll do
like they'll try to be like you know
it's aspirational Gary I'll motivate
them it ain't aspirational [__] you I'm
like I want to see that [__] yeah I'm
like that's gonna make people upset on
the flip side you coming on this podcast
right now and saying hey I'm empathetic
I've been on both sides of the financial
equation but even if you're making
minimum wage you do have most of us God
bless no matter what the financial
situation your ability to check your
white blood cells on a blood test in
around the world is high of course
there's third world countries of course
there's North Korea I get it there's
edge cases but starting that these
conversations where there's value like
I'm with you a hundred percent Gary you
know we're not we're not we're not we're
not crucifying anybody who's talking
about how many planes and trains they're
on and or drinking uh you know x amount
of champagne and carbs or crucifying her
but you know what the point of the
matter is Gary you and I we both come
from immigrant parents we come from a
day and age where we didn't have social
media to say what is the right thing to
do you know what maybe I can't afford
that but I know how to put a bunch of
ice in a damn tub and then and and and
reduce my inflammation you and I come
from parents and people who didn't have
this information or they said listen we
never go to the doctor because we can't
afford the doctor or they're wrong or
whatever the same way that I get
motivated from following whether garyvee
or somebody or or somebody about
medicine everything else well then you
know what if you're going to have all
these feeds on places to go and things
to buy and music no problem put some
feeds on there of AI Financial
intelligence how to help your health and
you know what slowly in the morning when
you look through these feeds maybe you
started to realize maybe I should do
something else BJ I'm so proud of you
brother I'm loving everything coming
this is going so well I literally just
was in Australia
and you know we both speak a lot we've
been able to cross paths I still always
finally smile when I think I love the
gangsterness of how long that goddamn
truck trip took because everybody like
you said they see the stages and they
don't realize your ass was oh I don't
know how long it's no joke but go ahead
let's go that's that's what I want
people to see but let's go you and I you
know I I've always liked your speaking
style as well because I think you you
know you don't have the same deck and so
in this talk I did three cities real
quick and I I did in the first place so
I brought it back in both spots improv
kind of I was like hey by the way talk
about these feeds when I open my
Instagram when I open my Tick Tock I'm
seeing people save a kitten off a tree
I'm seeing a three-year-old hug another
two-year-old I'm seeing Jets videos I'm
seeing sports like you you find what
you're looking for the fact that you
just went there as well which is like
you can say that like that we're getting
all this bad stuff why don't you and
engage and spend time on good stuff you
are more than welcome like Damon just
said to go to Instagram and Tick Tock
right now which are the predominant
Feats for a lot of people go to the
search type in financial literacy enter
things will show up you can then follow
nine of them you don't buy anything
I of course don't buy it get educated
back out type in eat cleaner and
healthier enter follow 912 people enter
back out how to fix back pain enter find
a bunch of content follow that tomorrow
and I have a funny feeling both of us
are going to get some tweets on this
everyone listening can change their feed
tomorrow by searching 20 positive or
informational or thoughtful things
following 20 to 50 accounts through your
little discovery of that
and watch what changes
become what you think about most of the
time Oprah said and we can do these in
simple forms you know you know what I've
learned you know listen they say that I
don't know whatever it is all the phds
will correct me there's a hundred and
whatever right 105 000 words in the
English language we use about six or
seven thousand of those words and if you
want to make immediate changes too my
little girl is seven years old she's
taught a new word every single week and
the word that we use B are the people we
are if we use words in our five thousand
to seven thousand words if we use words
like drama hate broke
um fight ignorant you know what I mean
then we're going to start moving there
so the words that I teach my daughter
every week is something like uh
interests if you know about interest
you'll earn it if you don't know about
it you'll pay it or love or Compassion
or empathy or save you know these type
of words it's the same as the feeds
we're watching right it's all of these
things that we use that slowly can
change us we always think too literal we
gotta go to school and learn Financial
intelligence right now we gotta do this
it's the small habits that get us
because when you when you stick to those
small habits you know we stick to bad
habits no problem or how I say the devil
thinks your life I'll give you an
example how I think about I told
somebody the other day they said well I
can't get nowhere in life right so when
you go on vacation when you say I'm
gonna get that pina colada with a double
151 shot as soon as I land I promise you
as soon as you land you got that goddamn
pina colada with a double thing and then
you go into more came out with a 150
150 miles you know I worked at Red
Lobster you had that 151 in there double
shot when I was a kid in the liquor
store the people that bought the 151 I
was like oof they're playing
let me to drink Mad Dog 2020. so that
that shows he was doing some other [__]
right I mean I thought it was only Grady
on Sanford and Son who drank that and
and ripple right or others
you're not gonna let yourself down when
you say I'm gonna do that but you know
what when you say I'm gonna go home and
read the chapter every night
you get the other things I I you know
it's the ones who it's the ones who
break those habits and are just as
disciplined about the positive things
whether they're scrolling through those
things or getting their one
in the back half of this podcast let's
go Mike bro we went very macro about
perspective mindset I think everything
we've just touched on is going to bring
a ton of value especially because we
went a little deeper on like change our
algorithms talk to me about
um in the micro any any sectors any
startups anything that has got you going
anything what's going on with actually
how about five minutes about what's
going on with you like what do you like
what's going on with you with content or
podcasts or or you know it's a good
question so I I I I think the obviously
the biggest uh to utilize what I have in
my my disposal I've come from a business
where I had to make a shirt Warehouse
I love content but I love content and
education my my my three Pete if I'm
gonna call it or the rest of my life is
going to be spent uh on drilling down on
education and giving access now there's
a couple of forms of access to give
right there's what we do every day you
and I have written many books on this
I'm on Shark Tank I do that but I've
become a little more of a garyvee Kevin
O'Leary kind of guy where I'm like
all right I wrote five books on it if
you guys don't get it then that's your
goddamn problem but the people that I
want to get it is the kids so my my
thing is that uh hopefully I've made an
impact with football hopefully I made an
impact with shark tank but my my my my
my really goal now is financial
intelligence and education for children
six to ten years old to start them off
thinking this and break the school
system that does not teach them this
because what happens if you don't teach
them this and then it's at at 18 years
old they can go get 500 000 worth of
student debt for uh for a career they're
not even sure they want to have then you
set our country up for failure because
then they don't have enough money and
when you don't have enough money like we
talked about earlier the cheapest things
to consume for food are made out of salt
sugar and butter and also we have a
bigger issue that's my that's my that's
my three Pete I want people to say Damon
changed the system and he got a whole
bunch of other amazing people to either
compete with him or see the value and
and that's why I had that book little
Dana learns to earn that did really well
hit Amazon number one for 24 hours
that's where I'm going good for you I
love that you know it's funny I love
that and you know what's crazy is I I
said something ironically on this point
uh this last week last week
I also improved into the stand-up
keynote style that I talk I'm like
remember when people used to talk about
saving money I literally you and I grew
up in an era where that was a
conversation that people were like that
was a word that people said there's not
a [__] under 25 years old that
even wraps their head around the idea of
like I'm gonna work
and I'm not going to go into credit card
debt I'm going to live within my means
and
save 10 or 10 20 of my take home we are
now in a place of zero savings
full debt full debt and we don't own all
to buy [__] all
and we don't own because now we rent an
Airbnb or we taking or we don't own any
equity and and that's critical but you
know listen even even as I talk about
investing like this you know listen you
are you are obviously somebody who broke
into the market and really have educated
us on nfts you know I I just did a post
I said you know when it's not sexy
anymore and you really love it that's
when it's time to invest because if you
know that you know you know you know e
and you know you need Bitcoin but you
need e to power all these nfts and
nobody's talking about it no more
[__] Bitcoin just went up from from I
don't know 15 or 18 dollars to to
whatever it doubled in six months right
so you already know that this stuff is
not going away but if you get financial
intelligence from us you can oh you
could have think about when would your
money have doubled in six months ever
yeah but if you're not thinking like
what you're talking about ownership
saving investing in early like Barbara
says buy houses now why interest rates
are too much you know why because nobody
else is buying and the interest rate is
going to reset in another six months or
a year so this is the time to buy
love I love and listen I think the six
to ten thing is massive and I think
you're so on it because I think look be
friends all this crazy [__] right the
nft part obviously that's a very
volatile asset similar to internet
stocks in the 90s we talked about that
at nausea yep on the flip side the
mission like what I'm doing with the
cards and the comic books and the toys
and the animations teaching kids at six
to ten which is my targets five to ten
in a lot of ways with what I'm doing now
later it will be more like yeah same
thing five to ten something yeah later
I'm gonna convert them into the stuff
like Marvel movies 18 to 25 all that but
Teach an accountant when people ask me
what's your favorite befriend I don't
it's like children I love them all I
created them but
when I tell you a countable ant if I can
get a countable Aunt to be cool as [__]
and a real thing to five to
ten-year-olds and humans at 18 to 30
like think it's a good thing to be
accountable it will literally reverse
forget about covid the great pandemic of
the last decade is a complete lack of
accountability literally everyone on
Earth is walking around pointing fingers
it's the government's fault it's that
person's fault it's Technology's fault
it's the it everyone's fault for
themselves
exactly
is that crazy
the accountability it it is critical I
mean you know those are the type of
books I'm trying to put out right uh
little Damon learns the barter little
Damon learns responsibility little Damon
learned all those types of things you
know you know and it's also we have a
job and that's the problem right you
know as we know our children are growing
up and they all want to be singers and
dancers and Tick Tock people and China's
changed in the whole game and they're
showing them but we want our children to
understand these processes early like I
say you know you don't teach I mean
maybe that this is exactly what they
probably did to all the players on the
Jets and the Knicks you don't teach
people to be a professional athlete when
they're 18 years old you teach them when
they're five now most of the Jets and
the Knicks were probably taught at 18
years old but you don't teach people to
play an instrument at at 20 and put them
in an orchestra you teach them at five
and six and I always break down the very
simple way that any person should
activate three dollars when three
dollars three million or three billion
come in the first style and so if you
teach kids this in the right way they'll
start thinking like this the first
dollar goes to feel what exactly they
need to buy because they need to live
the second is an investment an
investment can be in there in in their
in their uh public company in their uh
education whatever the case is and the
third dollar goes for what you would
like to have but don't have to have if
you don't buy it then put it into number
two number two sooner or later grows
because their Investments and to bucket
number one and number three but the way
that we live today like you said with no
ownership and no accountability we work
really hard yeah I get that we go and
buy number three first because we want
to treat ourselves that means we have no
money for number two and then we're
paying eighteen to twenty four percent
credit card interests are number one and
we never ever get out of the cycle teach
kids that at five to six to seven years
old they will start off with the
fundamentals on what to use with
financial ability well you battle on
that which is going to be massive I'm
gonna be battling on redefining success
some of these kids of like hey
if you're happy like real talk if you're
24 and you wake up if you're 33 and you
wake up
it and you live within your means of
making 79 000 a year yeah telling y'all
you're winning I know what you with all
the glitz and glamor I know the
hollywoodification listen I'm a
capitalist and an entrepreneur but the
capitalist entrepreneur Hollywood
American thing do not get tricked you
need to fight for happiness and being
content that doesn't mean being passive
being content and happy is Unstoppable
like I'm ambitious as [__] but there's a
level of contentness that doesn't lead
to the anxiety I'm going to tell you I'm
going to share with you a story that you
know I've never shared with anybody and
I just thought about it you know so
football was obviously doing really well
but I knew and I did my my math I was
like listen you know what when I came
into the market Levi's doing 18 billion
is doing three now I don't even know
where United color of benettons are I
don't know where these are so naturally
I'm not going to put myself first as an
ego sooner or later FUBU will have its
up finish down I realized I lived across
the street at the time from my office
and I had a Maybach because I wanted to
pull up of course all the time at the
parties in the club get the Maybach when
I think about it I'm paying for a
Maybach I'm paying for all this stuff
I'm flying private by the way you know I
gotta fly private that time because I'm
rich right when I really thought about
it the five people that saw me in in
first class uh going to La and the five
people that saw me coming back I got
them maybe two hours later but you know
what it was a difference of sixty
thousand dollars why do I give a [__]
about those 10 people that saw me or not
why did I need the Maybach to go across
the street to my office right what I did
was I went and bought a little property
didn't cost much but it was in the
middle of the Woods Way Upstate New York
and I said if everything goes to [__] I
got this little place and I'm not gonna
have to be and I can live I had enough
money to live I can now live and not
have to worry about being scrutinizing
hey weren't you the food would do no
food will suck yo you're broke I I did
that I put that away and thank God I did
but today now you can live anywhere you
want in the world and you don't have to
walk down the block you can have a [__]
ass little farm that you're super happy
with you can live in a little last
apartment no matter what and you can
really be financially secure with what
you're going to do and put that money
into what you really need and not have
to who gives a [__] about what other
people are going to think about you
because you know who's important what
your kids and your family and your wife
and your husband and your parents to be
okay and today we're in the world where
you don't have to live in the city you
don't have to have a big car you don't
have to have that [__] because this is
the only place they really need to see
you so who are you trying to impress at
the end of the day and that's the
important part of what what success is
to you success needs to be are you happy
with the ones that you love
I couldn't agree more man I'm listen I'm
sitting here and having an out of body
view of our combo and I'm like man
there's a there's there's a chance if
guys like us who are in the public
sphere right now for business yeah are
having a 30-minute conversation that we
just had
yeah we have a real shot because the
bottom line is
this was none of the conversation by
mature business men and women in the 60s
70s 80s 90s and 2000s and I think this
is huge because I think a lot of people
are very confused about how to get to a
good place and I think that there's a
level of compassion and empathy and
sympathy and good that is emerging and I
do believe in the power of Merit the
reason I love sports and business is
they're grounded in a level of Merit
that school and politics and corporate
are not and I just really hope that you
and I are the preview and there's others
out there right now doing the same thing
if we're the preview of the well-rounded
business combo I think we're gonna have
more successful financially and
definitely more emotionally successful
people and
I'm excited to be on that Journey
I am tilling I don't even need your
answer because I know just like I just
said whether is when I gave up
everything I started working Red Lobster
I found this thing called FUBU and when
I gave up everything and I moved that
little house I found this thing called
Shark Tank because I was able to clear
my head and do what the hell I liked and
I loved and that's when my greatest
successes came
I love you brother thank you for being
on any last parting shot that you want
the Vayner Nation to know about or go
check out or anything just check out
check out my podcast it's called that
moment with Damon John because I I
learned from Gary as well this is what I
love about it when people give answers
to a lot of questions a lot of us are
like parents and we talk because we know
that's the go-to I dig really deep in
the conversation say hold on don't rush
over that what happened that moment what
happened that moment I dig really deep
check out the podcast it's on every week
uh I think Monday and Tuesday black
effect podcast Network I heart and all
that good [__] I love you man thank you
so much you've done so much for my
family I'm not gonna mention it you
never mention it you never asked for any
favors I [__] love you man I love you
man that's why you're so great
[Music]
thank you